[Musique]
on a moins les atteins de la laïcité ont
explosé et elles ont été multipliées par
deux particulièrement en colère donc
avec de jeunes élèves et c'est un
phénomène évidemment des plus
préoccupants alors ces atteintes à la
laïcité concernent essentiellement le
port de tenue ou de signes religieux à
l'école donc
depuis 1989 avec l'affaire des trois
collégiennes voilées de Creil vous le
savez seul la droite a eu le courage de
proposer une loi pour s'opposer au port
de tenue ou de signes religieux
ostensibles à l'école
mettant un coup d'arrêt à cette pratique
destinée évidemment à
s'immiscer dans l'école et à
compromettre la neutralité qui doit
évidemment avoir cours à l'école
donc la loi de 2004 pose un cadre clair
mais on voit aujourd'hui qu'une nouvelle
offensive est à l'oeuvre de la part de
ceux qui professent à un islamisme
radical et qui se servent des jeunes et
adolescents pour être des porte-drapeau
d'une idéologie qu'il faut combattre
alors face à cette situation il y a deux
attitudes possibles il y a une première
attitude qui consiste à avoir une
réponse administrative au fond on sait
ce qu'a fait le ministre de l'éducation
nationale en édictant une circulaire
reprenant d'ailleurs des dispositions
qui sont déjà en cours à l'école donc il
y a là rien de nouveau et rien de
suffisamment fort qui puisse mettre un
coup d'arrêt assez pratique il nous faut
impérativement combattre la deuxième
réponse qui est la bonne de mon point de
vue c'est la réponse politique et cette
réponse politique pour qu'elle soit
suffisamment efficace il faut qu'elle
soit portée ou plus haut niveau de
responsabilité le président de la
République et la première ministre c'est
la raison pour laquelle hier j'ai posé
lors de la séance de questions au
Gouvernement une question adressée à
Elisabeth borne pour lui dire madame
vous devez intervenir madame la Première
ministre c'est votre rôle c'est votre
devoir d'autant que quand vous êtes
arrivés à Matignon vous avez dit je
pense à toutes les petites filles
évidemment dont elle voulait être en
quelque sorte l'exemple de
l'émancipation et de la réussite donc je
lui ai posé une question très simple et
était-elle prête à condamner le port de
ces de ces signes et de ses vêtements
religieux qui à l'évidence marque la
soumission de la femme et là hélas la
première ministre n'a pas répondu elle a
laissé son ministre d'éducation
nationale le choix de répondre
ce dernier n'a fait qu'une réponse de
constat on n'a pas besoin d'un constat
le constat on le connaît et de façon
générale ce gouvernement est très fort
pour les constats mais nous ce que nous
voulons c'est des actes et des décisions
donc voilà je pense que nous y
reviendrons dans les semaines et les
mois à venir parce que je crafore que
cette nouvelle offensive n'est pas finie
d'être mise en œuvre